et retour en france où l'état français
indemnisés ce lundi 7 127 mineurs de
charbon laurent ayant été exposés à des
substances toxiques après huit ans de
procédure la justice avait reconnu en
janvier le prêt j'ai vie le préjudice
d'anxiété chacun des plaignants ainsi
reçu et 10000 euros la banque de france
de son côté cédric de romanet un des
avocats des 727 mineurs de charbon
laurent espère que cette affaire servira
d'exemple pour le préjudice donc c'était
écouter
avec ce dossier
nous faisons nous avons fait très
largement avancé le la question de
l'indemnisation du préjudice d'anxiété
puisque c'est le sait la décision de la
cour de cassation dans cette affaire qui
permet d'étendre le bénéfice du
préjudice d'anxiété aux autres produits
cancérogènes mutagènes ou reprotoxiques
que l'amiante est donc ça ouvre
effectivement la possibilité pour pour
de nombreux salariés d'obtenir lorsque
leurs conditions de travail sont
dangereuses pour leur santé une
indemnisation le cas échéant et surtout
en réalité un un outil pour leur
permettre de mettre fin et bien des
conditions de travail qui sont
dangereuses